l'air émerveillé presque aillerie c'est
à se demander ce que regarder cette
lionne pour avoir ce regard si
particulier
laurent moreau présente son exposition
émotions animal à la galerie d'art ici
et ailleurs à versailles ce choix
diffèrent de son travail habituel le
globe trotter est routinier des modèles
humains et des couleurs ici le
photographe n'a fait ces photos quand
c'est bien c'est vraiment un choix
artistique et le rapprochement et de
dégager une certaine émotion dans ces
cesu animaux que je que j'espère presque
humain l'artiste se décrit comme un
passeur d'émotions
il a figé ces regards grâce à un
téléobjectif très puissant en se
rapprochant au maximum des bêtes pour
cette exposition
là c'est une série tout à fait
particulière qui a été initié à pompe
après un premier voyage au botswana où
j'ai voulu rendre des photos un petit
peu particulière des animaux avec des
émotions beaucoup plus vous voyez par
exemple ici on est on est des portraits
très très très rapprochée de de lyon ou
de l'yonne
voilà donc je ce que j'ai voulu c'est
vraiment redonné une une façon de voir
un petit peu différente pour les animaux
en mémoire de son grand-père l'artiste
s'est tourné vers le sépia un hommage
que laurent moreau partagera dans la
galerie d'art tout l'été jusqu'au 30
septembre